>>> THERE ARE NEW QUESTIONS THIS
MORNING ABOUT THE RESPONSE AND
WARNING FROM OFFICIALS IN THE
LEAD-UP TO THE WDFIRES THAT
HAVE COMPLETELY DECIMATED PARTS
OF MAUI.
WHEN ASKED IF HE THOUGHT THE
ISLAND'S SIREN WARNING SYSTEM
WORKED SUFFICIENTLY, THE MAYOR
OF MAUI WOULD NOT COMMENT.
HE SAID IT WAS A, QUOTE,
IMPOSSIBLE SITUATION.
OUR AFFILIATE KABC SPOKE WITH A
MAN WHO TRIED TO SAVE HIS HOME
UNTIL THE VERY LAST MOMENT.
>> I SAT UP ON TOP OF THE ROOF
AND BATTLED THE FIRE FOR ABOUT
THREE HOURS.
I COULDN'T DO IT ANYMORE.
THEN I SAID, I HAVE TO MOVE.
THEN I RAN TO THE OCEAN AND JUST
GAVE IN.
>> SO YOU LITERALLY SAVED
YOURSELF BY JUMPING THAT THE
OCEAN?
>> YES.
>> WHEN YOU TURNED AROUND AND
LOOKED BACK, WHAT DID YOU SEE?
>> DEVASTATION.
EVERYTHING.
EVERYTHING GONE.
>> NOW, THE NUMBER OF THOSE
KILLED IS NOW AT 55, BUT IT'S
UNCLEAR HOW HIGH IT COULD RISE
BECAUSE POLICE DO NOT KNOW HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY
MISSING.
>> HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE STILL
MISSING AT THIS HOUR?
>> REFER TO ME?
>> WHOMEVER.
>> HONESTLY, WE DON'T KNOW.
HERE IS THE CHALLENGE.
THERE IS NO POWER.
THERE IS NO INTERNET.
THERE IS NO RADIO COVERAGE UNTIL
WE GET SOME OF THOSE BASIC
THINGS SET UP, WE ARE NOT GOING
TO HAVE THAT NUMBER.
THERE IS ALSO GROWING FEAR THIS
MORNING THAT THAT NUMBER COULD
RISE SIGNIFICANTLY.
LAHAINA EVOICE RATESED BY THE
FAST-MOVING INFERNO.
THE MAYOR SAID THOSE BUILDINGS
HAVEN'T BEEN SEARCHED YET AND
THE DEATH TOLL RECOMMENDATION
BO
-- REPRESENTS BODIES FOUND
OUTSIDE THE BUILDINGS.
>> WE ARE WAITING FOR FEMA TO
HELP WITH THAT SEARCH AS THEY
ARE EQUIPPED TO HANDLE THE
HAZMAT CONDITIONS OF THE
BUILDINGS THAT HAVE BEEN BURNT.
>> THIS MORNING THOSE FEMA TEAMS
ARE ON THE WAY FROM CALIFORNIA
AND FROM WASHINGTON STATE, AND
THEY ARE TAKING CADAVER DOGS
WITH THEM.
NOW THERE ARE SERIOUS QUESTIONS
ABOUT IF, WHEN PEOPLE WERE
WARNED TO EVACUATE.
SOME SURVIVORS SAY THEY EITHER
DIDN'T GET EVACUATION ORDERS OR
THE ORDERS JUST CAME TOO LATE,
WHEN THE FLAMES WERE ALREADY
CLOSING IN.
AND WE JUST SPOKE TO A MAN WHO
SAID THAT HE NEVER HEARD ANY
SIRENS.
>> YOU ARE TELLING ME, THIS IS
NOT JUST ONE VILLAGE ON MAUI,
THIS WILL AFFECT ALL --
>> EVERY SINGLE PERSON.
EVERY ONE OF MY FRIENDS LOST
THEIR JOB BECAUSE THE BUILDING
THEY WORKED AT.
SO MUCH OF THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE
HERE WORK ON THE WEST SIDE.
IT'S LIKE WHERE THE HOTELS ARE,
WHERE ALL THE TOURISTS COME.
IT'S THE REASON WE DON'T HAVE
BEACHES.
EVERYONE'S LOST THEIR JOB, LOST
THEIR HOUSE, LOST THEIR FAMILY.
I THINK THERE IS GOING TO BE
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE DEAD, AND I
DON'T SAY THAT ANY CONSPIRACY
THEORY.
I LOOKED AT HOW FAST IT MOVED.
WE ARE ALL IN SLIPPERS, YOU
KNOW?
IT HAPPENS.
HOW DO YOU GET OUT THAT FAST?
IT'S ALL WOODEN HOUSES SUPER
CLOSE TOGETHER IN THAT
NEIGHBORHOOD.
YOU HAVE PROBABLY BEEN HERE ON
VACATION.
IF THERE IS A WAY YOU CAN HELP,
HELP HERE.
IT'S NEEDED.
EVERY SINGLE HOME IN LAHAINA IS
GONE.
IT'S LIKE I SAID BEFORE.
IT'S APOCALYPTIC.
>> YEAH.
THAT EXPLANATION COMING TO BILL
WEIR, WHO IS THERE IN MAUI.
BILL, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
LISTEN, WE HAVE SEEN THE
PICTURES.
YOU ARE THERE.
WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE?
WHAT DOES IT FEEL LIKE?
>> Reporter: IT IS SO HARD.
IT GETS YOU IN YOUR GUTS,
VICTOR, WHEN YOU SEE, WHEN YOU
TRULY TAKE IN THE SCOPE OF THE
DEVASTATION IN LAHAINA TOWN.
I WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO BE THERE
YEARS AGO WHEN IT WAS AT ITS
MOST CHARMING AND IT'S PARADISE.
IT'S ONE OF THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
PLACES.
TODAY IT'S UNRECOGNIZABLE.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE SET OF A WORLD
WAR II MOVIE IN THE MIDDLE OF
FRONT STREET THERE.
EVERYTHING, MAN MADE
STRUCTURALLY, IS BLACKENED AND
CHARRED AND JUST MELTED.
IT SMELLS.
IT REMINDS ME OF THE SMELLS I
CAME ACROSS IN PARADISE,
CALIFORNIA, AFTER THE RECORD
DEADLY FIRE IN THE UNITED STATES
HAPPENED THERE, BECAUSE EVERY
PETROLEUM PRODUCT, THE PIPES,
THE PLASTIC, FIBERGLASS BOATS IS
MELTED INTO THIS SOUP NOW
FLOATING IN THE HARBOR THERE.
AND MOSTLY YOU TALK TO SOME OF
THE FOLKS.
I TALKED TO THE GENTLEMAN YOU
JUST SAW THERE, EDDY GARCIA, A
LOCAL FARMER, HE WAS CUTTING
FURIOUSLY A FIRE BREAK ON HIS
FARM TO STOP THE FLAMES THE DAYS
BEFORE AND IT ACTUALLY PAID OFF.
HE LOST A LOT, BUT NOTHING
COMPARED TO HIS NEIGHBORS WHO
HAVE NOTHING.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE TIME TO GRB
THEIR CLOTHES OR EVEN A PASSPORT
BEFORE THEY FLED.
NOW THERE IS THAT WORRY.
I HEAR IT AGAIN AND AGAIN.
THEY ARE WORRIED THE DEATH COUNT
WILL GO HIGHER AND HIGHER, AS
YOU MENTIONED.
THEY START TO SEARCH BUILDINGS.
RIGHT NOW IT SEEMS THEY ARE
FINDING FOLKS WHO WERE TRAPPED
ON THE ROAD, EITHER IN THEIR
CARS OR TRIED TO TAKE REFUGE IN
THE WAVES OF THE PACIFIC.
I HEARD A STORY OF A WOMAN WHO
STOOD?
THE WAVES OR WAITED THERE FOR
EIGHT HOURS.
THE MAN NEXT TO HER DID NOT
SURVIVE.
AND SO WHEN THEY START GOING
THROUGH THE STRUCTURES, SOME OF
WHICH ARE JUST TURNED TO ASH,
SADLY, SADLY, THOSE STATISTICS
HAVE TO CLIMB.
AND NOW IT'S JUST PEOPLE ARE
GOING -- SORT OF THE FIVE STAGES
IN REAL TIME OF GRIEF,
UNDERSTANDS WHAT'S LOST,
UNDERSTANDING HOW TO COME
TOGETHER.
IF THERE IS A PLACE IT COULD BE
DONE, IT'S HAWAII.
I TALK ABOUT THE COMMUNITY, THE
STRENGTH OF COMMUNITY IN THIS
STATE.
ESPECIALLY ON MAUI, WESTERN
MAUI, THERE IS VERY TIGHT
COMMUNITY THERE AS WELL.
BOY, THEY NEED EACH OTHER NOW
MORE THAN EVER.
>> CERTAINLY DO.
THERE IS REAL CONCERN ABOUT THE
LACK OF WARNING THAT A LOT OF
SURVIVORS ARE TALKING ABOUT.
THE MAYOR JUST SPOKE WITH NBC
NEWS, BILL, AND WAS ASKED, DID
THE EMERGENCY SIRENS WORK?
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> SO, EVERYTHING HAPPENED SO
QUICKLY.
I CAN'T COMMENT ON WHETHER OR
NOT THE SIRENS SOUNDED OR NOT,
BUT I KNOW THAT FIRES CAME UP SO
QUICKLY AND SPREAD SO FAST.
>> BILL, YOU'RE ON THE GROUND.
WHAT ARE PEOPLE TELLING YOU?
>> Reporter: THAT'S WHAT I HEAR
AGAIN AND AGAIN, IS JUST THE
SPEED OF THIS.
WITHIN MINUTES, LESS THAN
MINUTES, THE EMBERS WERE BLOWING
SO FAST AND PEOPLE DIDN'T HAVE
ANY SORT OF EARLY WARNING
SYSTEM.
WE ARE HEARING MIXED REPORTS OF
SOME PEOPLE GOT SOME ALERT TO ON
THEIR PHONES SIMILAR TO TSUNAMI
WARNING, WHICH THEY ARE USED TO
HERE IN THE ISLANDS.
BUT THE SPEED OF THIS.
THE ESCAPE ROUTES ARE SO
LIMITED.
YOU HAVE THE UPCOUNTRY,
MOUNTAINSIDES AND OCEAN AND A
FEW ROADS IN BETWEEN.
ONCE THE TRAFFIC WAS BACKED UP
THERE, PEOPLE NOWHERE TO GO.
I TALKED TO ONE GENTLEMAN, BILL,
FAMOUS ART GALLERY OWNER HERE,
WHO ESCAPED HIS GALLERY ON A
MOTORCYCLE.
HE THINKS THAT MADE ALL THE
DIFFERENCE BECAUSE HE WAS ABLE
TO GO AROUND SOME OF THE CARS.
>> BILL WEIR, WE APPRECIATE YOUR
REPORTING.
WE WILL KEEP WATCHING THROUGHOUT
THE DAY AS THE SUN COMES UP
THERE AND THEY GO INTO SOME OF
THE BUILDINGS.
>> JOINING US IS A RETIRED CHIEF
OF THE MAUI FIRE DEPARTMENT,
LIONEL MAN TALL VO.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
I WANT TO START HERE WITH WHAT
WE ARE LEARNING ABOUT ALERTS AND
WARNINGS.
YOU SAY THERE HAVE BEEN FIRES
LIKE THIS BEFORE.
THEY WERE ABLE TO HAVE BEEN
CONTAINED.
HOW DO THE ALERTS AND WARNINGS
PLAY INTO THE CONTAINMENT AND
MINIMIZING THE DAMAGE AND WERE
THERE ENOUGH HERE?
>> YEAH, I'M NOT SURE EXACTLY
HOW THIS EVENT UNFOLDED.
IN THE PAST, WE WERE FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
OF SOUNDING THOSE ALERTS.
SO ACTIVATING THE ALERT SYSTEM
WOULD SIMPLY REQUIRE JUST A
REQUEST ON THE RADIO OR A PHONE
CALL TO THE EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
CENTER.
>> YEAH.
THAT'S A REAL QUESTION NOW.
IT WAS WORKING IS?
DID THOSE CALLS HAPPEN?
I WONDER WHAT, CHIEF, YOUR
RESPONSE IS TO HEARING FROM THE
MAYOR THAT THEY HAVEN'T GONE IN
THE BUILDINGS YET AND WHAT THAT
MEANS FOR THE DEATH TOLL.
>> YEAH, IT'S DEVASTATING.
I'M SURE FOR ALL THOSE INVOLVED
AND THOSE WHAT ARE DOING THE
WORK OUT THERE.
WE ARE STILL IN THE PROCESS OF
WAITING FOR ASSISTANCE FROM THE
URBAN SEARCH AND RESCUE UNITS.
THAT'S COMING IN.
WE HAVE THE NATIONAL GUARD.
WE HAVE THE CAPABILITY OF DOING
IT OURSELVES, BUT IF IT YOU CAN
IMAGINE THE DEPARTMENT'S
LIMITATION IS, YOU KNOW, ONE
BUILDING.
THIS IS A WHOLE VILLAGE, MANY
STRUCTURES THAT NEED TO BE
SEARCHED.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME.